you coincide with our shows here in New
York City we've partnered with AT&T to
release the catch KOCO app now listen to
this with the catch KOCO app you can
catch me Conan O'Brien eating my
favorite deli sandwiches at various
locations around New York City
and at home now to demonstrate I played
the catch KOCO app earlier today right
outside the Apollo Theater
take a look hey Colonel Brian here I'm
at the catch KOCO app and trying to
catch myself this is the most
narcissistic thing I've ever done the
corned beef on rye paying the mortgages
of cardiologists since 1922
[Music]
the first player who catches all 15
Conan's gets to meet me in person this
week in New York City where you can see
me eat a sandwich live and in person
no talking there will be no talking you
look at me and I get to pick the
sandwich that's it for all the details
go to chim koco.com slash catch Coco the
catch Coco app is available for download
on your Apple or Android device be sure
to check it out and thanks again to our
friends at AT&T
[Applause]
you